[Música]
cientos de emigrantes de nicaragua y
honduras partieron este sábado hacia el
norte del continente con el propósito de
llegar a eeuu los grupos conforman la
que es la primera gran caravana de 2022
pero todavía no saben si podrían cruzar
hasta guatemala
en australia este domingo en una nueva
jornada de apelación se decidirá si se
mantiene la cancelación de la visa de
novak djokovic por regulación de kobe o
si se le permite participar en el
abierto de australia el tenista fue
detenido nuevamente
y en la copa africana de naciones hoy
dos encuentros serán el espectáculo en
garúa buscando la clasificación para
octavos de final se enfrenta a nigeria
contra sudán y egipto contra guinea
bisseau equipo que sufrió bajas por
tobey 19 tenemos reportes de nuestro
enviado especial
feliz fin de semana y bienvenidos a una
nueva emisión de noticias en france 24
los saluda andrés meza muñoz empezamos
en centroamérica la primera caravana de
emigrantes de 2022 salió esta mañana
desde honduras hacia eeuu se trata de
cientos de personas que huyen de la
violencia y de la falta de oportunidades
en sus países con destino a la unión
americana pese a que desde hace meses el
gobierno de joe biden les ha enviado
mensajes para que desistan de cruzar la
frontera andrés granadillo nos cuenta
más en busca del sueño americano cientos
de emigrantes en su mayoría hondureños y
nicaragüenses partir hacia eeuu en la
primera caravana de 2022 en las redes
sociales está diciendo de que va a haber
un gran gran apoyo de las instituciones
como decirte mire que los senadores
dijeron y se reunieron y dieron una
carta dirigida al presidente by day y
dijeron de que supuestamente no iba a
dar un tal cese desde el pp ese no sé
cómo para darnos la oportunidad de
entrar para buscar cómo trabajar allá
para nuestra familia hombres mujeres y
niños son impulsados a salir de sus
países debido a la falta de empleo y la
inseguridad todos los países del mundo
estamos pasando necesidades de que allá
en eeuu pues lo pensamos llegar a un
mejor futuro para nuestra familia de
jamis y los migrantes continúan su
caminata a pesar de que el gobierno
estadounidense los ha instado en
repetidas ocasiones a no intentar cruzar
hacia su país ya que no hay por el
momento una política migratoria
establecida de hecho a partir de enero
la justicia obligó a bailén a
restablecer el programa quédate en
mexico creado por su antecesor donald
trump y que obliga a los solicitantes de
asilo permanecer en este país mientras
se soluciona su situación jurídica es
por esto que algunos optan por buscar
visados en mexico en 2021 131 mil 348
personas solicitaron asilo según la
comisión mexicana de ayuda a refugiados
y en reino unido- políticos opositores y
grupos ciudadanos piden la renuncia del
gobierno británico que enfrenta su peor
crisis tras la revelación de dos fiestas
de funcionarios realizadas en down
instruido durante el confinamiento por
kobe 19 la primera de ellas fue una
reunión de tragos con presencia del
primer ministro boris johnson en mayo de
2020 y la segunda fue una celebración de
su personal en abril de 2021 en la
víspera del funeral del prince felipe y
mientras la reina hacía duelo en soledad
por el estricto confinamiento además
según el 'daily mirror' en esta oficina
se realizaron lo que llamaron viernes de
vino presenciadas regularmente por
johnson el líder del partido laborista
ofreció una rueda de prensa para sumar
apoyo contra el premier
tenemos otros grandes desafíos que
enfrenta este país desafíos grandes
tenemos un primer ministro que está
ausente está literalmente escondido en
este momento y no puede liderar
es por eso que he llegado a la
conclusión de que tiene que irse por
supuesto que hay una ventaja en el
partido en que se vaya pero en realidad
ahora es de interés nacional que lo haga
así que ahora es importante que el
partido de torre haga lo que tiene que
hacer y se deshaga de él
a partir de hoy en francia hay
restricciones más estrictas para que los
pases sanitarios sigan siendo válidos y
de acuerdo con el ministerio de salud
más de medio millón de personas están en
riesgo de que sus documentos sean
desactivados ya que a partir de hoy se
requiere una dosis de refuerzo mientras
el gobierno plantea introducir incluso
restricciones más severas al convertir
el pase sanitario en pase vacunal lo que
implica que una prueba pcr negativa no
sería válida
y tres jueces federales australianos
considerarán este domingo la apelación
de novak djokovic contra la cancelación
de su visa y decidirán si el tenista
número uno del mundo puede participar en
el abierto de australia que comienza
este lunes entre tanto el deportista
volvió a la detención migratoria con su
visado dos veces anulado por
regulaciones de kobe djokovic no está
vacunado y quedó en el aire la excepción
con la que ingresó al país por estar
recientemente recuperado algunos de los
mejores jugadores del mundo han dado su
opinión sobre la situación antes del
comienzo del torneo más detalles con
nuestro corresponsal camilo montoya
desde melbourne
y luego de la decisión del ministro
federal de inmigración de australia de
cancelar por segunda vez la visa de
novak djokovic el tenista fue detenido y
pasará la noche en el mismo hotel de
migración donde estuvo durante cinco
días tras su llegada a australia los
ojos del mundo están puestos en la
audiencia programada para este domingo a
las nueve y media de la mañana fecha y
hora locales de melbourne allí se
discutirá la apelación radicada por los
abogados de djokovic un dato importante
es que la corte decidió que la audiencia
no será presidida por un juez sino por
tres es decir por la sala plena esto
implica que sea cual sea la decisión que
tome ninguna de las partes tendrá la
opción de apelar la defensa del serbio
solicitó esta posibilidad con la cual el
gobierno no estaba de acuerdo mientras
tanto varios de los turistas que van a
participar en el abierto de tenis han
reaccionado rafael nadal rival directo
de djokovic para disputar el título dijo
que está cansado de la controversia a la
cual ha calificado como un circo además
según él ningún jugador es más
importante que el torneo y que con o sin
djokovic el abierto de australia será
genial la tenista japonesa naomi o xhaka
actual campeona torneo de grand slam
calificó la situación como desafortunada
y dijo que es triste que muchas personas
vayan a recordar al djokovic por lo que
está pasando la situación migratoria y
djokovic podría decidirse finalmente
este domingo un día antes de que inicie
el torneo la organización ya tiene un
plan de contingencia en caso de que el
tenista número uno del planeta no pueda
defender su título cambiamos de tema el
servicio metereológico de estados unidos
emitió una alerta del tsunami para la
costa este del país además de
inundaciones en hawai tras la erupción
de un volcán submarino en el pacífico
sur que provocó un tsunami que llegó
hasta la isla de tonga y que encendido
las alarmas en varios países de la
región las olas de 1,2 metros arrasaron
con varios muros de las viviendas
costeras en la capital de la isla nación
las autoridades han pedido a los
ciudadanos permanecer alejados de las
playas
[Música]
un tsunami golpeó nukualofa la capital
de tonga en todo el archipiélago los
habitantes fueron evacuados de las
costas desde el viernes debido a varias
erupciones de un volcán en una isla
deshabitada gonzález
[Música]
a 65 km de la capital se encuentra el
hunga tonga y hunga ha'apai el estruendo
se escuchó hasta fiji a más de 800
kilómetros de distancia la columna de
humo visible desde el espacio alcanzó
los 20 kilómetros de altura en una
erupción submarina cuando es poco
profunda el contacto agua magma es muy
explosivo la gente piensa que el agua
apagará el volcán pero es lo contrario
el agua se vaporiza de aumentar la
explosividad del conjunto por lo que
tenemos erupciones muy violentas esto
fue suficiente para preocupar a los
servicios de alerta de samoa americana
que activaron los protocolos de
emergencia así como en los territorios
de ultramar franceses de wallis y futuna
estamos emitiendo una alerta de tsunami
para samur por favor resguardados en
terrenos más altos
las autoridades de fiyi aconsejaron a la
población que protegiera las reservas de
agua dulce de lluvia ácida y de las
cenizas mientras que nueva zelanda
monitorea el nivel de las aguas de sus
costas orientales ante la posibilidad de
que aumente la marea el continuo de la
copa africana de naciones hoy con duelos
del grupo de que esperan pasar a octavos
de final
vamos con de nuestro enviado especial
federico que de barberena
egipto no puede permitirse otra
decepción en si quiere seguir en carrera
en la copa africana de naciones tras un
magro debut con derrota frente a nigeria
los faraones necesitan los tres puntos
ante guinea bissau en su presentación
los dirigidos por el portugués carlos
queiróz o mostraron un fútbol lento y
sin ideas para romper a la defensa
nigeriana fue particularmente
decepcionante la tarea de mohamed salah
la gran figura egipcia quien jugó en una
extraña posición de centrodelantero y se
vio poco abastecido de la tarea del
entrenador generoso buscar la manera de
que la figura del liverpool pueda entrar
más en juego y ser más determinante para
el centro del campo la buena noticia
para egipto es que recuperan a su vice
capitán amir el zulia por el lado de los
zorros el cómic 19 ha golpeado fuerte a
este equipo y contará con bajas
importantes como la de madrid morís
gomis y joseph méndez dos habituales
titulares así como su entrenador básico
can de quien no podrá estar en el banco
la buena noticia es que recuperan a su
capitán yonath méndez el 15 ha
recuperado del hobbit 19 y se espera que
pueda tener algunos minutos en el
partido
y antes de despedirnos los invitamos a
visitar nuestra página web www france24
puntocom en portada detalles sobre la
erupción volcánica que enciende alarmas
en el pacifico y también qué pasará con
el futuro del tenista novak djokovic
hasta aquí esta emisión de noticias en
france 24 gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]